nancy pelosi begged the media to help
her sell the democrats 3.5 trillion tax
and spend bill
so do you think you need to do a better
job at messaging and going forward how
do you sell this if ultimately you have
to i think you all could do a better job
of selling it to be very frank with you
pelosi's asking the media for help but
the media can't say what's actually in
this thing because if they did the
entire country would revolt
it's stalled now thank god and the
democrats are panicking that we'll start
picking through this boondoggle and
report what's in it well we did that and
here's what we found
the most expensive bill in american
history 4.3 trillion dollars
when we built the interstate highway
system this is eight times the cost of
that
they want 400 billion dollars for
government day care that's right
hundreds of billions for federally
funded babysitters literally cradle to
the grave
billions in subsidies to stay home
instead of work and give unions total
control of the economy
largest tax increase in american history
two trillion dollars
higher business taxes than socialist
europe and even communist china taxes
passed down to consumers with higher
prices fueling more massive inflation
bringing us back to the carter years
50 billion dollars in death taxes makes
you pay more taxes after you die so your
family doesn't get as much
80 billion
tax hike on small businesses which just
got slaughtered during the pandemic
taxes on energy taxes on employers and
if you smoke cigarettes the cost of a
pack just went way up big time tobacco
taxes here
doubles the number of irs agents
and none are going to be allowed to look
at hunter biden just at the rest of us
let's irs agents spy on your bank
account if you have a balance of over
600 bucks which is pretty much everybody
this is the green new deal that most
democrats didn't want to touch because
it was too politically toxic so they
just hid everything in this thing
seven billion dollars for the green new
deal climate police
they wanted to fund the real police but
fund the climate police
10 billion dollars in green new deal
slush funds to indoctrinate college
students
two billion dollars for green job
training now remember obama already
tried this and he couldn't point to a
single green job he created
this blocks american energy exploration
which increases our dependence on the
middle east and russia great areas
27 billion dollars for a green bank
we're getting ripped off guys this is
where donors go for cheap loans it's
that simple
forces americans to use wind and solar
in places where it isn't very sunny or
windy
california already did this and it
caused rolling blackouts
they basically want to turn america into
california no thank you
we'd like to keep our lights on
billions in kickbacks for green donors
and activists 25 million dollars for
butterflies
that's right 25 million for desert fish
i didn't even know they had fish in the
desert
and 25 million dollars for mussels
not these
although i'd take the money
a four billion dollar slush fund for
radical activists to tear down racist
infrastructure
not sure a train station can be racist
but okay to me it sounds like
taxpayer-funded statute toppling
maybe the george washington bridge is
coming down you never know
it makes crossing the border much easier
makes it harder to deport illegals and
spends a hundred billion dollars to give
amnesty to 10 million illegals
free college tuition for illegals free
tax credits and welfare for illegals and
biden wonders why the illegals are
coming from south america to get here
half a billion dollars for ready
culturally appropriate school lunches
what does that mean taco tuesdays
seven billion dollars for ivy league
schools the wealthiest schools in the
country
the word equity plastered all over this
thing that means reverse racism
a quarter trillion dollars to bail out
health insurance companies
didn't we just give those guys a
trillion dollars last year during the
pandemic they need more money
free housing for convicted felons
beat your wife here's some rent money
penalizes getting married
keeps single mothers stuck on subsidies
and includes taxpayer-funded abortions
grants to treat people for loneliness
i'm sorry but i'm not paying for someone
to find dates there's an app for that
let's bring in senior advisor to
president trump stephen miller to help
us digest all the spending you know it
it's true this actually is in this 3.5
trillion stephen and that's why
they don't want us to know what's in it
well you hit the nail right on the head
and i'll give some friendly advice to
republicans on capitol hill you can't
just keep talking about the price tag
you have to talk about the policy inside
of the bill
it's 2400 pages for a reason if you just
wanted to spend a few trillion dollars
you could do that in 50 pages this isn't
like a stimulus bill where you're
plowing money into existing programs you
are fundamentally reordering all of
american society it's just one example
this bill
requires health care providers to be
trained in equity which is code word for
critical race theory so you're going to
go to the hospital with a medical
emergency you're going to need a
tracheotomy and the nurse won't be
trained in airway obstructions but
they'll have all the latest knowledge on
the books from ibra mixed candy i mean
this is madness this bill is the most
radical piece of legislation in our
lifetimes
it's basically the green new deal
combined with critical race theory
combined with massive amnesty and open
borders combined with
the complete destruction of the american
economy there's tax hikes here on
american energy there's tax hikes here
on american manufactured goods there's
the death tax in here there's a tax
credit for rich people to give money to
their favorite universities presumably
to teach more critical race theory i
could go on
you're so right it's not just one thing
it's everything a liberal has ever
wanted to do for the last decade miller
you nailed it we got green new deal we
got amnesty we got bailouts we got
critical racer they shoved everything
into one pie
and
now we're arguing over a price tag but
we're not talking about the ingredients
yes and these ingredients are going to
make this country sick and it's time for
people to start talking about what's
inside this thing here's the analogy i
would give real quick imagine you went
to a restaurant they overcharged you
massively but they also poisoned you
when you spent a month in the hospital
then you had to write a yelp review
would your whole yelp review just be man
that was an expensive meal or would you
maybe mention oh by the way they
poisoned me yeah this bill is filled
with poison page after page after page
gop wake up tell people what's in the
bill yeah just tell them the truth tell
them what's in it so we don't have to
pass it before we find out stephen
miller everybody thank you thank you so
much for coming on waters world hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else